Has the Penguin always been the proprietor
of a nightclub in Gotham?
And what does the Iceberg Lounge mean for
the character and his criminal operations?
Keep watching to find out.
Oswald Cobblepot, known to many as The Penguin,
has proved to be quite the monocle-wearing,
umbrella-wielding thorn in the Dark Knight's
side since his debut in December 1941's "Detective
Comics" #58.
The character has definitely evolved over
his 80-plus years of existence, going from
bird-themed crook to politician to businessman
and back again.
He's been a little silly, like his portrayal
by Burgess Meredith in the 1966 "Batman" TV
show, and monstrous, like when Danny DeVito
played him in "Batman Returns" in 1992.
"You gotta admit!
I played this stinkin' city like a harp from
hell!"
Some of the more drastic character alterations
tend to disappear from version to version,
but every now and again, some new twist to
the Penguin will stick around.
For instance, something that has relatively
recently become a key element of the Penguin
is his position as the operator of the Iceberg
Lounge.
The seedy nightclub been around for just under
30 years, debuting on the pages of "Detective
Comics" #683, in March of 1995.
In his early days of terrorizing Gotham City,
the Penguin stood as a figurehead of the criminal
underworld.
Lacking superhuman abilities or the more homicidal
tendencies of his supervillain peers, Cobblepot
was content simply committing robberies and
stabbing his supposed allies in the back.
So, he eventually decided to open the Iceberg
Lounge as a means of proving he'd become a
legitimate businessman.
Of course, it was a front all along.
Batman, of course, sees right through it and
keeps tabs on what's going on behind the scenes
at the lounge.
Over time, he has used it and its patrons
as a resource to study up on the happenings
of Gotham's criminal underworld.
Other members of the Bat-family have visited
the Lounge for vastly different reasons.
On one occasion, in the "Batman R.I.P."
storyline, both Robin and Batgirl went there
to forcefully gather what intel they could
from the Penguin on the missing Batman's whereabouts.
And former Robin Jason Todd took over the
Iceberg Lounge for himself in the "Red Hood:
Outlaw" series, ousting Penguin from power
for a time and holding him captive.
Despite its prevalence on the page, a proper
live-action theatrical Iceberg Lounge has
only recently come to fruition.
Director Christopher Nolan's "Dark Knight"
trilogy and the DC Extended Universe lacked
both it and the Penguin.
"The Batman" marks its first live-action outing
at the movies.
Colin Farrell's scarred, calculating take
on Oswald Cobblepot serves as its proprietor
and uses it as a cover for his criminal activities.
Prior to "The Batman," The Iceberg Lounge
did appear in one live-action production:
"Gotham."
The Season 3 finale teased it, and it inevitably
became a focal point of Season 4.
The Gotham nightclub has appeared in lots
of animated projects, however.
It's been featured on the shows "The New Batman
Adventures" and "Justice League Unlimited,"
as well as the animated movies "Batman: Mystery
of the Batwoman" and "Batman: Assault on Arkham."
"Sorry, we're full up tonight.
Shoo, shoo!"
It's perhaps been featured most prominently
in video games, though.
The "Batman: Arkham" franchise endures as
one of the most widely acclaimed Batman adaptations,
tossing elements from a variety of Bat-projects
into a giant, grimy, gothic melting pot.
Multiple games in the series also feature
the Iceberg Lounge in varying capacities,
allowing players to explore it in all of its
glory as Batman himself.
The Iceberg Lounge featured first in "Batman:
Arkham City" within the Cyrus Pinkney Institute
for Natural History.
After Batman battles the Penguin , his numerous
cronies, and his horrifying "pets," Tiny the
shark and Solomon Grundy, you're free to look
around, solve riddles, and collect the building's
hidden Riddler Trophies.
In both "Arkham City" and its sequel, "Batman:
Arkham Knight," the Iceberg Lounge also serves
as a combat challenge map.
But you couldn't possibly chill at the Iceberg
Lounge in real life, right?
It's an entirely fictional place.
Well, maybe not.
There is an Iceberg Lounge fans can visit
in Central London.
The venue promises "champagne, cocktails,
exceptional food, live entertainment, and
decadence" at a vaguely Batman-inspired corner
of the city appropriately called Park Row.
Fans can experience their own little slice
of Gotham at a handful of other stops without
fear of being mugged by Joe Chill.
Park Row includes attractions such as Pennyworth's
restaurant and bar, an art gallery called
Rogues Gallery, the Old Gotham City bar, and
the dinner-and-a-show spot Monarch Theater
— all paying subtle homage to the Caped
Crusader and his bevy of villains.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.